[Music]
receding gums are unattractive symptoms
include tooth sensitivity and oral
health issues but many people avoid gum
grafting surgery because they've heard
that it's painful well after years of
research dr john chow the sponsor of
this segment developed pinhole gum
rejuvenation the first minimally
invasive treatment to correct gum
recession and he's joining us today to
tell us and show us how it works hello
dr chow
hi mercedes how are you great we are so
happy to have you joining us now most
people think of receding gums as an
older person's problem but isn't it true
that even teenagers can have gum
recession
well that's right it is a common notion
that receiving gums only affects older
people but that's not always the case
improper brushing is a common factor in
the development of a gum recession even
among teenagers other practices
associated with gut section are gum
disease orthodontic treatment and
genetic factors now how is pinhole gum
rejuvenation done and how does it
compare to conventional gum grafting
well
unlike conventional gum grafting pinhole
is done with no scalpels most switches
are no stitching it requires minimum
down time the entire procedure is done
through tiny pinholes made in the gums
first the gum tissue is numbed
we can local in the static then using
special instruments that i designed it
trained the dentist freeze the gum
tissue and guides the gums down to cover
the exposed roots the print will heal
quickly and most patients report little
or no pain and requires virtually no
downtime
that is quite a transformation now can
multiple teeth be treated at the same
time
yes that's what's exciting absolutely is
true uh because treatment takes only
minutes per tooth a trained dentist can
treat it can treat 10 teeth or more in a
bar an hour with minimum downtime
this highlights one of the unique
advantages of primogram rejuvenation in
that it's quick
and it's easy
dr chow you've trained over 3 500
dentists in pinhole gun rejuvenation
what inspired you to invent pinhole
one day i was sitting under apple tree
and something fell on my head
and
so i got this inspiration all of a
sudden that i should do something about
this this pain and
and recovery time the people need for
gum uh grafting so
uh but seriously my like most dental
inventions
pinocchio rejuvenation was developed to
fill the need that i saw in my own
patients why should treatment for gum
research be so uncomfortable sometimes
requires such extended recovery time
and this invention has been so well
received that to date i've personally
trained over 3 500 dentists from across
the country and around the world and due
to demand i'm continuing new online
classes for dentists now people can find
a trained dentist in pinhole skills in
most cities and towns across the usa
including exciting beautiful las vegas
we love that and if you want information
on pinhole gum rejuvenation we've got
all the info you need and also doctor
training all you have to do is go to
pinhole gum rejuvenation dot com we'll
be right back